hey guys it is the 26th of august today
my name is Jess MacDonald and you are
watching games but news
so we already got the Sony factoid that
50% of PlayStation 4 owners never owned
a ps3 but now it's come out that they're
actually poaching gamers from their
competitors a Nielsen study provided two
tech site recode has indicated that
while those new ps4 owners may not have
owned a ps3 31 percent of them did have
an Xbox 360 or a wait comparatively 17%
didn't earn any console from the last
generation this then seems to suggest
that perhaps console brand loyalty isn't
as significant as we thought one thing
worth mentioning is that consumers were
only asked to specify the consoles they
currently owned and not once they had
previously so save you just sold your
ps3 last week that wouldn't have counted
as new earning 1 let me know what your
console situation is currently next up
called Julie wants you to buy snack
foods and they're willing to give you
exclusive content for the upcoming
advanced warfare for your trouble
Activision have teamed up with Mountain
Dew and Doritos for a fuel up for battle
promotion in an effort to perpetuate the
biggest gaming stereotype in the world
I'm not altogether sure how much protein
is in either of those snacks to help you
fuel up but if you spend your dollars on
specially much products you can unlock
cosmetic items for use in advanced
warfare supply drops system
shelling out on green soda and turning
your fingers orange with Dorito dust can
also earn you double xp bonuses but for
those of you worried you'll miss out if
you aren't so keen on a sugar rush it'll
mainly play into the hands of gamers who
want the unique touch of a fancy looking
helmet or exoskeleton the promotion
which kicks off on October 6 in the spy
us exclusive and items 1 within it won't
be available elsewhere until February of
next year next up a new pokemon game is
on the way and it's coming from the dev
team
to tekken the aptly named pokemon tekken
mashup a pokken tournament is set for
release in 2015
poor japanese are cave taken producer
Katsuhiro Harada commented on the
fighter saying whether you're a casual
player a regular player or a hardcore
player anyone who likes Pokemon can have
fun so if you're anybody at all with an
interest in Pokemon this one will be a
go up no longer will you have to suffice
with turn-based Pokemon bashing from the
safe zone behind a pokeball you can
finally get all up and Jigglypuff space
to get him to stop using sleep on you
I'm guessing ask me a question of the
day be sure to let me know if this was
the Pokemon game you're looking for and
which Pokemon game you'd like to beat
the crap out of you know if you could
that is it for me today I'll be back
same time tomorrow as always let's have
a fun time imagining all the Pokemon
punch-ups you want until then
[Music]